hello everybody my name is markiplier
and I'm here with yamimash say huh hello
I'm back I got the boy he's back and
he's out he's got a creepy new model
that is not more gonna do Televi max uh
why hey I'm almost dead you son of a
[ __ ] okay yo oh yeah okay now that
that's over with you can't kill me cuz
I'll kill myself okay I won't kill you
man oh oh man okay alright now that
we're done with that we're gonna do
melee only we are playing GM abandoned
Metro Metro Metro and in this map we go
into the depths of Hell in order to seek
out the Holy Grail or something like
that I don't know what are we doing III
I don't know man like you all don't look
to the map I just downloaded I don't
know anything about the hey you go first
okay are we going right in there go man
go is it Jim shift was jumping Crouch
are you not a half-life professional
like I am a rush okay now that's over
with since I got the camera I'll go
first oh this looks nice Hey look error
messages I love it
nothing beats error messages yeah I know
the feeling a train is gonna come past
and kill us uh kill you I got such pro
skills that I would dodge right away
what is that did you see those eyes no
no I saw red eyes
talking of I read probably error
messaging nothing was not error eyes it
was an error it was eyes eyes red glowy
I have eyes for you they love you well
everyone there's eyes for me
Oh red eyes all my all my fingers they
love me only oh yeah now they love me
do they fangirls out there do you love
me or yamimash well of course they're
gonna say they love you oh come on you
don't give yourself enough credit
are you yeah no no yeah yeah yeah okay
you go hammer we got a bunch of
branching paths over here so let's just
take this nice and bottles
I'll suppose I'll destroy these boxes oh
there's an air vent mark really you know
you want to go in it uh why go on I'm
going you go now I'm right behind you
going
oh it just leads to the other area it's
nothing really huh okay Wow I was
disappointing
yeah well a lot of things in life are I
think you'll learn yes lizzi's Hey look
another vent ah that's under water
what's happened to you whoa it's kind of
a creepy place but nothing's happening
so far it's building up to something
mark I promise you what what - wait man
building up to what I don't I don't know
we might even be skipping forward -
basically played this before I know
exactly what's gonna happen
is that true oh my god oh my god I'm
underwater there's no air down here oh
here we don't have an oxygen be it will
be fine oh we're good I'm still getting
error message but not that many like
randomly there error messages how are
you where'd you go yummy oh hey you uh
oh hi okay hey which way did you really
swim is majestic right
yeah it's freaky and stuff anyway okay
so I don't know what's going on here I'm
gonna see a palette for roar roar roar
maybe those the first monster and it was
just trying to growling roar roar roar
hey where are you I'm over here honey uh
hello I heard something in here yeah you
look a bathroom no way I'm sure nothing
bad happens in the bathroom wonderful
anyone's taking a dumb nope no one's
taking a dump in here well so far this
is boring
where's the skiers looks those high star
ratings are this what are they thinking
yeah I have no idea we're two brave and
two horror game experts who yeah are
nice my handsome cunning we laugh in the
face of danger and whatnot exactly and I
laugh in the face of error messages too
huh ah I don't see anything nothing
maybe through this door notice nothing
hey I got this one
hang on come over here awesome wait this
is just a computer this is nothing this
is absolutely nothing there's nothing
now this is not one of your videos
starts playing on the computer how
amazing would that be that'd be creepy
as hell but since it's map I think it
was made before I started making videos
but anyway it's nothing here something
is bound to happen eventually I promise
you
Yeah right see a liar yamimash you think
I don't know your tricks wait what well
I just I mama maybe I did make this map
you never know no then here
no there's nothing anywhere why'd you
hate the boxes so much what did they do
to you I don't know I just uh I don't
even know what we're looking for I
didn't even know why we're here whoa
what's Metro what a metro you should
know what a Metro okay this is where we
came in cuz that's where that was so I
think we gotta go down I gotta do now is
just yeah we need to go down farther
okay down the stairwell here like sdp
will over again might be maybe that's
what they're going for
oh we're going way down now this is
getting pretty deep maybe this is where
we were supposed to go in the first
place who need you for the past five it
is I don't know shut up it's color
commentary
we're expert blog oh god this is getting
bad
yeah I know so sir Sir what's with this
I'll see how I look at the top and you
just check the bottom I'm uh I got your
back
this is Dullahan that I got it whoa all
right all right yeah okay I'm going I'm
going
all right it's getting better get in
there get in there get in there
wait for me - good ha ha you're now such
a big baby I'm a mass you gotta be brave
my brave man hmm
I heard that hear that what what what
play that now there's some noises coming
from down here it's just you talking no
there's noises I heard it
you're going crazy are you go right I'll
go left
all right right is always the right way
all right
so if anything scary happens yeah me I
hear you don't hear that no it's like I
don't go whine in my ears
something's going on here and I'm gonna
figure out what it is oh I already hope
it gets you whatever it is what are you
laughing I want you to scream ha ha ha
already faking yeah you're faking no I
saw something there with the thing
standing in the way there was something
I didn't believe you I saw something
everyone out there you saw something too
Oh taunting happening I found a
generator but it's not working um I'm
still in this bloody vent
oh I led to a dead end haha silly
British man I've come all the way back
now you might see well it like it peered
in it went away I'm not joking it was
there I'm not going crazy got me back I
just twice you think you've seen some
eyes or something yeah I'm not crazy
you're crazy for digging that I'm crazy
yeah there's a lot of blood here we're
never gonna be able to find each other
again you know this right of course we
win no you don't worry up this is like a
maze
serious yeah it's like a frigging maid
butters well I'm still in this little
dad whatever it is tunnel tunnel um it's
gonna take me a while to get to you cuz
I'm moving really slowly yeah I'm trying
to find I think I saw a way out but I'm
trying to find back to where you are so
that I can lead you to the exit oh very
very helpful thank you um I think I'm
going the right way okay I found the
generator again so I'm ah okay I'm got
found my way back so just come to the
sound of my voice god damn house hello
oh hey you uh this is where I saw the
thing it was right here standing in this
area oh yeah I bet I bet yeah it was
okay follow me follow follow follow here
Infini hallo
you shut up don't make fun of the way I
run
would your crew bond wins this is the
America whoa you see that yeah I poked
it for a second haha I knew something
was gonna happen yeah it makes a
happening finally ha ha I'm gonna go
through them I just got a skull on it I
don't trust this door it doesn't seem
right ah shut up little backup just men
Oh
ha why sorry why I'm backin up a getting
your son of a [ __ ] I'm coming to get
you buddy you sure I didn't need it how
could you do that to me I trusted you
who I was trying to get out of the way
his lips but ha ha ha it's gonna take
you a whole blog let's go take me to get
back yeah I'm lost I've lost
don't go anywhere I've got I better I'm
on my way I am running as fast as
humanly capable the incorrect way I
think I'm not going the right way take
some pictures while you're gone if
you're dead I'm not even oh god I'm not
going the right way you made me go the
wrong way I'm sorry
dami yamimash murder anyway yeah I'm so
angry just filled with such anger there
we go here's the stairwell no there's
nothing here anyway I've checked
everywhere there's nothing here nothing
in your brain who uses our RPG even
though I was gonna use an RPG on the
door I don't use it when you're right
there in front of a that does not cool
man yeah you said to me before we
recorded this uh-huh when it's out get
your RPG out and that's exactly what I
just did I never said that in my life
you did it to me I didn't eat making
stuff up now that is a total lie
markiplier handbook and I followed it
perfectly uh-huh yeah that's what yeah
you're such a liar man we do go slow in
this little crawlspace have you been
here please um I'm waiting for you I'm
calling you shut your face you murdered
me well you at least your respawn isn't
there oh yeah I bet there's a command
that lets you teleport to other players
oh yes probably her problem
it's like the Minecraft command I don't
know I'm almost there I'm almost out of
the hallway I'm gonna I hate you I hate
you you do it's good
are you sure that is in the monsters
that are coming to get yo hey that for
trying to murder me
I'm skeleton with like bloody skin I
first bought a I'm almost there
yeah if you see a skeleton with like ah
okay
alright so was there anything actually
in here there's nothing here what was
the point of oh never mind I set this
machine huh well what are you and I see
pity there's another generator here but
it's not working again so okay um I
guess we got up keep looking for it's
difficult to quickly I don't wanna lose
you
oh that's so sweet you don't want to
lose me alright you go right I'll go
left
oh okay fine hmm just look for something
that looks important
hey wait this is wait we this is my way
job my territory this is my bit alright
whatever fine I'll go the other way okay
and I found a gate this gate here that
seems like the way forward I'm just
gonna use my massive muscles to pull it
off its hinges yeah yeah I don't know
move it doesn't move you ain't been
working out it's on it it's impossible
if I can't move in no one can have you
seen my muscles uh yeah I mean no seeing
the size of my biceps no one has seen
the size of your biceps oh there's
something here there's a way to move
forward but this okay there's it's not
moving
nah maybe there's got to be a way to get
it's gotta be a way to get this open I
think we y'all in CIL's it it will upset
it I know the end yourself you're so
ugly and full of holes you you can't
even stop a drop of water or I don't
know I'm not good at this um you you you
Russ you oxidize too quickly it when
exposed to the elements yeah so thin
that and that both of us could walk
through at the same time you put on some
weight
housing a good answer oh god I can't I
can't even cheat
we can't even cheat this is stupid not
all matters do this map is dumb
there's the rapper's starboard wait wait
don't give up on it so oh yeah I'm
giving up on it if it another chance but
there's blood here there's a boot on the
floor
a bloody that's a sign throw the poo at
the door and the door will fall down ah
okay if you say so yamimash well isn't
it obvious
no these two asses who loser it didn't
work what do you know it's hard I got
this you threw it wrong hang on oh wait
no clip are you doing my I can't no clip
why can't I know clip okay no clip ah
losing my mind it's just a Dooley
breathing uh there's gotta be like a
button in here somewhere that we we've
missed we've missed a button or
something uh did you try you use the was
it the grabber gravity gun in the
physics gun okay that's impossible
all of this it's not working all of this
is impossible it's just it's just a
trick this whole map is a big joke it's
just a troll they rated it highly just
so we ended up playing it and then we
was in this situation exactly they did
it to travel us yeah what is tell me a
secret Tim yeah okay just calm down
everybody
okay uh okay that's through three tubes
of painted this this means something I'm
trying to save for this I'm real I
follow you three tips of paint to hold
on after one on the right ones on the
third shelf ones on the second shop
makes sense three two three that spouse
CAC uh-huh CAC CB c CB c 3 2 3 3 you
know that's that's why I'm an o2 so I'm
trying to figure out what a CBC me
haha I can't deal with this anymore of
it I'm going arctic crazy
Obed Oh Bob's your students in the
rocket landed baba you're loud no son of
a [ __ ] came alive around ma no God your
name yeah that is pretty great help you
please don't
a cat do it I can't take it off that I
can this is impossible it's impossible
oh hey I guess wait wait stay that says
don't mean okay well I didn't work
either
oh what a surprise so that would it
broke down I know um let me go pray
about that cow oh good
I haven't explored the area oh wait no
wait hang on play ball no never mind
false alarm there's a shovel I found a
shovel
well congratulations that doesn't help
us at all there's absolutely nothing
here there's nothing here this is all
just a big fat lie a doll a dinged-up ha
ha it's all a lie this is the worst is
worth anything
damn that kind of it
I got still here I've given up on life
random I give up on everything
everything is wrong I hate it hmm you
know we should settle this a different
way how okay come on
what come in come in I don't wanna talk
about it stop moving some of it yeah now
you can't get out the door okay
oh we're going to is um where I sir what
are you doing um all right we're gonna
use our tool guns uh huh huh if you look
through the entire inventory in the tool
gun there has to be something that will
be hindered all
on the tool I don't think so that door
is like on there I don't know know why
it is like on there all I got is
dynamite here so I don't know I'll do it
uh I don't think it'll do it but here we
go it's a metal door with holes in it
I'm lining it up with dynamite a little
bit hippie dynamite limit how do i how
do I hate it
uh I didn't have a huh
no no six six six six
you need to line it up get a match out
how about a rocket launcher Oh that'll
do it I just moved him around do
anything did your thing why'd you get
close enough to get killed by it you're
gumming it doctor
this whole map is stupid and I hate it
I'm gonna die alright I'm done here
we're done here I give up we give up so
anyway so thank you everybody so much
for watching this has been one of the
worst zoom out horror map ever who gives
this a 4 out of 5 we didn't do anything
wrong right yeah all right so anyway
Thank You y'all meows for joining me on
this terrible map um yeah this was this
is really fun yeah yeah yeah so thank
you everybody so much for watching click
the annotation for more videos that I've
done and we've done click the annotation
to go to yamimash this video we're gonna
do another one here so thank you again
and as always we will see you in the
next video
ah
look at my life
Oh
tell me about it
Oh Andy